but it's not just Energy prices going up
here you know London rents are going
through the roof and you know this is
not because of Vladimir Putin or because
of the war in Ukraine obviously
um
but for me the biggest problem that
happens when you are
blind to ideas such as when money is
given out it depresses the value of
money
is it also lead you to be blind to other
questions like where did that money go
and anyone who watches this channel will
know that I've been going on about this
in the beginning of code which is during
covid a huge amount of money hundreds of
billions of pounds you know trillions of
US Dollars went from governments to the
rich and the obvious consequence of that
is that the rich get richer all the new
people get poorer
inequality increases and Ordinary People
find it harder to live because you as an
ordinary person are competing with the
rich for limited resources if they've
got if they've got way more money they
will get more and you will get less um